I wasn't going to tell this story but um
so you know what this is like I got a
job and I couldn't do it because I had
to do I was contractually obligated to
do another job and I was really sad cuz
I wanted this job so bad and I was
walking around a flea market in La just
like oh my God what's going to happen is
everything going to be okay I was so
nervous and this young girl ran up to me
and she goes can I just stop you for one
second and I'm like okay and she goes
I'm a psychic and I'm like okay and she
goes my grandmother's a psychic my mom's
a psychic and I'm just I need to tell
you something you just got blocked from
doing something and it's going to be
okay but you're not on the path you
should be you're supposed to be like
you're supposed to be like a Drew Barry
more
what no and it meant the world to me and
it was like such a sign I was like
everything's going to be okay I just
have to hang in there and everything's
going to be okay cuz I'm going to be
like a Drew Barrymore oh my God if I can
only be half
way